es el momento de hablar de salud en
directo a América de France 24 y hoy con
un tema especial para ello me acompaña
mi compañera Mara Romero Buen día para
ustedmar Buenos días Ángela Bueno hoy no
es un día cualquiera hoy es San Valentín
mucha gente lo celebra y nosotros
queremos aprovechar para hablar de la
atracción y del amor pero desde el punto
de vista de la ciencia y de la salud sí
es un tema particularmente escurridiza
difícil de Pues de aterrizar porque a
pesar de que muchas veces y muchas
personas se han esforzado en explicarlo
desde la ciencia tenemos que empezar
diciendo que hay muchísimos factores
sociales culturales que influyen en Cómo
vivimos la atracción el sexo el amor que
no siempre se pueden explicar
simplemente desde lo científico pero
empecemos por la atracción por este
primer momento en el que nos gusta
alguien muchas veces ha intentado
responder esa pregunta no cómo hacemos
qué es lo que influye para que alguien
nos guste o no desde ese punto de vista
se ha intentado explicar de muchas
formas por ejemplo hay estudios que han
intentado explicar esa atracción a
través del olor particularmente a través
de las feromonas que son unos compuestos
químicos que emitimos por ejemplo es lo
que emiten las flores para atraer a los
insectos entre los humanos también
sucede mandamos información así y hay
estudios que concluían no que los
hombres están más atraídos a las mujeres
en momentos en los que las mujeres son
fértiles a raíz del olor desprendido por
las feromonas de eso Por supuesto puede
tener parte de verdad pero no deja de
dejar por fuera muchísimas cosas como
por ejemplo relaciones que no sean
exclusivamente heterosexuales Por eso
preferimos ir más al campo de la
psicología y explicar más una lista de
factores que recogieron en la
universidad de Southampton que parecían
ser comunes por ejemplo quizás a veces
más allá de las feromonas los
científicos así puede ser tan sencillo
como la proximidad Cuanto más expuestos
estamos a alguien más probabilidades hay
de que esa persona nos pueda gustar No
por ejemplo también La familiaridad
buscamos características que reconocemos
la reciprocidad Perdón es más probable
que nos guste alguien que nosotros
pensamos que nos puede también que le
podemos que haya un intercambio allí y
luego en temas de atractivo físico
también se ha intentado explicar muchas
veces no no es la simetría de las caras
que porque anteriormente se nos hacía
pensar que la gente era más saludable
hay muchos de estos estudios que han
terminado siendo también pues
desestimados porque estaban plagados de
muchos de estos estereotipos al finales
pues atractivo físico también es un
constructo social y es muy difícil de
predecir y muy subjetivo mal si la
atracción se convierte en amor en el
mejor de los casos con millones de
factores que lo pueden producir que no
sucede Pues muchas veces asociamos el
corazón no como el órgano del amor
cuando en realidad es en su gran mayoría
el cerebro el que influye en esto en las
primeras etapas del enamoramiento en
esos momentos en los que parece que solo
se puede dedicar atención a esto no nos
sentimos totalmente imbuidos por esa
sensación está relacionado con unas
hormonas que segregan nuestro cerebro
particularmente la dopamina y la
norepinefrina que son unas hormonas que
regulan por ejemplo que se liberan cosas
cuando hacemos cosas que nos hacen
sentir bien estamos hablando por ejemplo
de sexo pero también de pasar tiempo
juntos de hacer actividades que nos
gustan no la noripinefrina también es
conocida además como la hormona que nos
hace estar alerta en momentos de riesgo
tenemos un cóctel hormonal en nuestro
cerebro en ese momento sucediendo que
incluso puede tener influencia en que
tengamos menos hambre o menos sueño No
todos esos poetas malditos que hablan de
que no pueden dormir porque están
enamorados podrían hasta tener una base
fisiológica que explicará esta sensación
Pero sabemos que el amor no es solo esta
explosión inicial sino que también se
trata de vínculos de construir vínculos
duraderos y allí También sucede algo a
nivel hormonal No ya más allá cuando
estamos hablando de vínculos de apego de
relaciones más sólidas más duraderas
estamos hablando de la oxitocina y la
vasopresina no por ejemplo la oxitocina
es una hormona que regula varios
procesos fisiológicos también
emocionales relacionadas con
sentimientos de empatía también de calma
Y que además por ejemplo se produce en
un combo de momentos bien extraños no
durante el sexo pero también durante el
parto y media en la lactancia que tienen
en común Pues que son momentos
precursores de generar un vínculo
emocional y por eso ahí pues se ve esa
relación Eso es lo que nos hace
diferentes ahora cómo explicamos desde
la neurociencia la otra parte del amor
que son las rupturas por supuesto al
final es muy sencillo la dopamina es la
misma hormona que se activa en los
circuitos cerebrales del sistema de
recompensa es lo mismo que nos pasa
cuando tomamos por ejemplo sustancias
como alcohol también como drogas o
sustancias psicoactivas o cuando comemos
incluso Dulce no es esa sensación de que
tú haces algo te hace sentir bien y para
poder seguir teniendo esa sensación cada
vez tienes que tomar más es uno de los
círculos que llegan por ejemplo a abuso
de sustancias es decir cuando estamos
privados al final de esa sensación no
deja de haber algo muy parecido a un
síndrome de abstinencia que es real es
fisiológico también cuando termina al
final una relación amorosa algo parecido
también sucede con de cocina no deja de
ser eso no teníamos unas cosas que nos
hacían a sentir bien también a nivel
fisiológico hormonal que dejan de estar
disponibles para nosotros un amor que no
siempre es binario Mari Más allá de eso
está demostrado que el amor es bueno
para la salud cuéntenos por qué Pues sí
se ha demostrado que las personas que
han sostenido vínculos afectivos largos
tienen mejor salud mejor salud
cardiovascular menos indicadores de
cáncer mejor Salud Mental y hay varios
estudios que han recogido las cifras
para saber por ejemplo en qué riesgo de
muerte no como en la mortalidad de las
personas en este caso por ejemplo
casadas o solteras uno de las cifras hay
entre un 10 y un 15 menos por ciento
menos perdón de riesgo de muerte
prematura también hay un descenso de la
mortalidad en este caso más pronunciado
en los hombres que en las mujeres eso
tiene algo de sentido porque al final
uno de los factores que influye aquí es
el cuidado mutuo que se da en las
relaciones no el estar pendiente el uno
de otro y sabemos que normalmente pues
tradicionalmente las mujeres a veces han
salido su más los hombres que al revés
en estas relaciones pero hay algo
interesante y es precisamente hablabas
de lo no binario no de salir un poco de
esta caja del matrimonio para empezar en
muchísimos matrimonios que son
profundamente infelices o incluso
violentos en los que esto no tendría
ningún sentido aplicarlo Pero es que se
ha demostrado también que estos vínculos
de amistad estos vínculos Perdón
afectivos No necesariamente tienen que
ser el matrimonio o un vínculo de pareja
sino también pueden ser los vínculos de
amistad no tener vínculos sostenidos
afectivos con las personas más allá del
amor Más allá de lo sexo afectivo
también beneficia nos beneficia a largo
plazo claro ayer leía que a veces esta
idea del amor de pareja y del amor
romántico nos aleja de otras formas de
amor y además el amor romántico no es
una regla y no lo necesitan todas las
personas gracias a usted mal gracias
Ángela